In this lecture we're going to talk about
color. You probably notice that I studiously
avoided talking about color so far. This lecture
we're going to talk properly about color.
Color is something that's really important
for animals. Almost all animals that see can
see color to some extent.
And perhaps one reason why color is important,
if you think about our ancestors' foraging
for food, perhaps it was important to be able
to detect some red fruits against the background
of a green tree. So in this lecture we're
going to talk about what color is, where it
comes from and how we can deal with color
images in the computer. So far we've been
dealing with gray scale images. And how we
can write the computer program to determine
what color some object is.